for the year in
southern nevada you could probably play
tennis if you're like thick-skinned
aren't you good you're good at tennis
right
in college you did did you play in high
school i got credits for teaching yeah i
did so if we played it'd be pretty much
6-0-6-0 you'd dominate well i'm old now
so that's why we go to paddle paddleball
right yeah or no pickle pickleball
that's it that's paddleball
that's a new one for me new game we're
going to start hey i want to show you
this first day of winter all right we're
going to show you the strat cam look at
the shot looking at the strat uh and you
know it's you know goes around slowly
right the restaurant yeah it goes around
so
i actually knew someone that put their
purse down and it went around they lost
it because it went around
it went around the other end of the
restaurant
nobody stole they just went around
yeah
you got to go up there check it out
great great breakfast great brunch up
there all right this morning
temperatures in the 40s so not quite as
cold as what we've seen lately where we
were at freezing on sunday today low 40s
ellis was the chilliest spot i could
find in the valley this morning right
around 2 a.m 40 degrees there on leonte
41 currently outside 46 for sky canyon
along with centennial spring valley 52
48 for north las vegas 53 sunrise manor
53 also whitney ranch mountains edge 51
rhodes ranch and also spanish trails
including anthem right now currently at
44. we'll switch up those neighborhoods
to make sure everybody's included that's
coming to the next weather cast 41 in
indian springs 46 for you over the hump
and got a lot eight news now viewers
there like we said lots of clouds but no
rain here we saw some sprinkles way off
along i-40 here zooming out however
there's the curl in the atmosphere
that's the low here's all that moisture
off out and see and that trough is going
to pull this up towards us
not tomorrow but the better chances like
we said come now on thursday and also
friday especially which is christmas day
i better look at that future cast closer
look at the valley here now in southern
nevada there's a look at thursday
morning not a big issue clouds for sure
but then look at this we start to see
this fill in a little bit showers
increase later on today on thursday
especially in the evening hours and
overnight for christmas eve morning but
now looks like saturday for christmas
day all this starts to clear out just
leaving only slight chances of isolated
showers overnight low though in the low
40s again 37 for summerlin cold for you
cold also for southern highlands at 38
along with saint rose parkway anthem
there in the high 30s 32 for from 44 for
searchlight overnight here's your
forecast 41 degrees overnight partly
cloudy skies it will be chilly overnight
but not too cold and we saw those
temperatures below freezing earlier this
week and last week those winds stay
light for now 58 for tomorrow increasing
those clouds from a lot of clouds for
tomorrow
we'll be near average our almost 56 so
we'll be slightly above average here's
your eight day forecast now with santa
clearly in view take a look at christmas
eve and christmas day there's those area
showers for friday temperatures actually
getting up to 64 degrees on thursday and
then chilly next week for the last few
days of 2021 here's a better look now at
christmas day 50 chris loves this one
57 degrees
showers and wendy
what can i make myself dance again let's
just see we'll go back and then we'll
we'll skip this is what he does after he
aces a serve this is right in his looks
like his opponent does that move
it's just dehumanizing
the best part too is that i wear those
elf pants too just
hey that's quite a visual